Hollywood has been plotting a remake of
Katsuhiro Otomo Akira for almost two
decades the project has a complicated
and somewhat controversial history
Leonardo DiCaprio remains attached as a
producer and he seems determined to make
the live-action Akira
a reality we've got all the details
right here
when Akira dropped in 1988 bootleg
copies spread across US campuses like
wildfire Leonardo DiCaprio was a
teenager when Akira hit the States and
it's clearly made a big impression on
him the Oscar winner has been a big fan
of anime for years now Akira in
particular his production company Appian
Way got involved with the Warner
Brothers LED remake back in 2008 and the
first thing DiCaprio did was put the
fans at ease he told MTV I'm a big fan
of Japanese anime I know there's a lot
of loyal fans out there of the project
and diehard fans so we're going to try
to do the best job we possibly can and
we're not going to make the movie until
the script is in the right shape after
earth writer Gary Whitta was the man
tasked with penning the screenplay
according to witih and akira trilogy was
being quietly planned but the first
installment faltered director Rory
Robinson best known for 2013 sci-fi the
last days on Mars later revealed that
producers put the project on the back
burner for financial reasons
he said they couldn't get the budget
under 200 million bucks for that draft
which was a bit rich for what was
proposed as an r-rated movie with no
stars Warner Brothers had Robinson put
together a sizzle reel and the Irish
filmmaker even shot some test footage
for the film recreating some iconic
Akira shots
akira takes place three decades after
tokyo is leveled by a devastating
explosion the mega city that springs up
in the aftermath is Neo Tokyo home to
the young biker gang that the story
revolves around when one of the boys
develops powerful psychokinetic
abilities the city faces destruction all
over again
it's a big-budget story which is
probably why dicaprio and his partners
at warner brothers decided to film the
whole movie in California making Akira
totally in state means it qualifies for
an eighteen point five million dollar
tax credit allocation Warner Brothers
confirmed the studio told deadline we
are thrilled with the opportunity to
shoot akira in california the
availability of top-notch crew members
plus the wide variety of location
choices and predictable weather are
second to none needless to say fans of
the original are deeply concerned about
this move the setting and aesthetic of
Akira are central to its appeal and
recreating this in the Golden State
won't be easy taiko y TT was attached to
the Akira remake before his first Marvel
movie made him a household name in
Hollywood the New Zealand er opened up
about his plans for Akira while
promoting 2017 s thor ragnarok revealing
that he intends to take inspiration from
Otomo's original manga not the anime
whitey Chi told The Hollywood Reporter
who wants to see a shot-for-shot remake
of the film nobody also you have to make
it entertaining I think it's really
dangerous to make these films very
serious cyberpunk there was a time and a
place for that and there may be a time
and place for that tone again but you
have to make fresh takes on things Y TT
is reportedly co-writing the movie with
always be my maybe scribe Michael DeLong
KO when Dazed caught up with whitey T in
2018 he revealed that the script was
still in the early stages of
developments he said I haven't really
started to get my head around it yet
there are six gigantic books to go
through it's so rich but Akira is one of
my favorite films my mom took me to see
it when I was 13 and it changed my life
filming the movie in the States is one
thing but setting it there is another
entirely in April 2019 production Weekly
shared what appeared to be the first
OPS's for DiCaprio nytt sukira and it
made some pretty grim readings for fans
of the source material there were a ton
of fundamental changes including moving
the action from Neo Tokyo to neo
Manhattan the synopsis read when a young
man's telekinesis is discovered by the
military he is taken in to be turned
into a super weapon and his brother must
race to save him before Manhattan is
destroyed by his powers Canada is a bar
owner in neo Manhattan who is stunned
when his brother Tetsuo is abducted by
government agents films like John wick
prove that Manhattan offers the perfect
palette for this kind of story and some
fans may have been willing to get on
board with this had it been the only
change in Otomo story teenagers Canada
and Tetsuo are longtime friends not
brothers the fact that Canada now owns a
bar suggests that he and Tetsuo will be
aged up for the movie but according to
another industry website this won't be
the case backstage has since released
what appears to be a casting call for
akira and it reveals that producers are
looking for age-appropriate actors to
play Tetsuo and kannada who will be 17
and 18 years old in the movie the whole
neo Manhattan idea actually dates back
to when Warner Brothers first negotiated
a deal for Akira in 2002 Blade director
Stephen Norrington was hired but
concerns about his involvement were
raised after he told The Hollywood
Reporter that he planned to make the
story quote more accessible presumably
to Western audiences when Norrington
departed the project the studio turned
to Rory Robinson and Gary Whitta who
tried to remain faithful to the source
material on a technicality
in their version of Akira Manhattan had
been sold and was legally foreign
territory owned and populated by the
Japanese does this mean the leads would
have been Japanese probably not widow
told Collider it wasn't a new Tokyo but
there were Americans who kind of lived
in little Americanized porter's of it I
felt that was a way to do a kind of cool
Western Eastern fusion of the two ideas
not fully Japanese not fully westernized
in other words he dubbed the cool bikes
and the whole cyberpunk thing but he
wanted a Hollywood star to lead the
charge
Keanu Reeves once came very close to
playing the part of Canada in the
live-action Akira movie when the
Robinson wid a version fell through
Warner Brothers hired Book of Eli
co-director Albert Hughes and Harry
Potter screenwriters Steve cloves Reeves
became their target but despite some
constructive talks the matrix star
ultimately decided to pass it was a huge
blow for the project Warner Brothers
reportedly shut down Akira's previz
department and sent most of the staff it
had working on the film home it turns
out Reeves wasn't the first actor the
studio had contacted about the role of
Canada Warner Brothers reportedly
reached out to Garrett Hedlund Chris
Pine Michael Fassbender Joaquin Phoenix
and even Justin Timberlake while Robert
Pattinson Andrew Garfield and James
McAvoy were said to be in contention for
the role of Tetsuo when fans discovered
that a version of akira starring Justin
Timberlake was a very real possibility
they lashed out one person who was
particularly vocal about the all-white
short list of actors was George Takei
the Star Trek legend predicted that
Warner Brothers would have a huge bomb
on its hands if it whitewashed Akira
he told The Advocate if they're going to
do that why don't they do something
original because what they do is offend
Asians the tradition in Hollywood has
always been to buy a project change it
completely and flop with it
I think it's pointless so I thought I
would save Warner Brothers a bit of
failure by warning them of what will
most likely happen if they continue in
that vein this is exactly what happened
to Paramount after it cast Scarlett
Johansson as the major and it's remake
of the 90s anime classic ghost in the
shell' the studio ultimately admitted
that the whitewashing backlash badly
hurt the movie which was a critical and
commercial failure it seems like Warner
Brothers is heating the signs a casting
call put out by the studio appeared to
confirm that it was looking for Asian
actors for the lead roles run all night
director Djalma call it Sarah replaced
Albert Hughes in 2011 but it wasn't long
before he hit a brick wall he was
already working with a reduced budget of
90 million dollars and sources suggested
that Warner Brothers wanted to drop that
figure again aiming to spend as little
as 60 million on Akira
in 2014 collet-serra confirmed that he
was still trying to get a scaled-down
version made unfortunately the Spanish
director also made some incredibly
ill-advised comments about Oh Toma story
he told coming soon
nobody's interesting Tetsuo is
interesting because weird happens to him
and Canada is so 2-dimensional that's
part of the Japanese culture
they never have strong characters
they're used as a way to move the other
philosophy forward unsurprisingly
collet-serra soon found himself out of
the picture Jordan Peele was linked to
Acura not long after his oscar-winning
direct or II old debut get out premiered
though he quickly decided that taking
charge of a Hollywood remake wasn't for
him the actor and filmmaker told Horror
website the 13th floor that he was
capable of directing the new Akira he
just didn't want to peel said Akira is
one of my favorite movies and I think
obviously the story justifies this big a
budget as you can possibly dream up but
the real question for me is do I want to
do pre-existing material or do I want to
do original content at the end of the
day I want to do original stuff appeals
rejection came on the back of George
Miller declaring himself out the
Australian director was asked about
Akira after 2015's Mad Max fury road
became a roaring success but he couldn't
fit it into his busy schedule he told
Yahoo there was talk of Akira but I've
got so many things on my dance card I
don't have time to do everything in may
20 19 Akira fans got some much-needed
good news regarding the long gestating
live-action adaptation Warner Brothers
had finally set a release date tyka
whitey d's film was going to hit
Cineplex --is on May 21st 2021 the
studio confirmed but another huge
development was just around the corner
in july 2019 news that YTD had agreed to
a deal to helm another thor movie broke
it was great news for Marvel fans but it
was a cruel blow for those who have been
waiting patiently for Akira the proposed
schedule for a Thor love and thunder
clashed with that of Akira and the
latter film was put on hold indefinitely
as a result
YTD remains attached but Akira is now
back in limbo and the headache continues
any new version of Akira still has to go
through katsu hero Otomo when the
Japanese artist writer and director sat
down with Forbes in 2017 he revealed
that he was quote basically done with
Akira having finished his original manga
and helmed his very own anime version
Otomo confirmed that he's happy for a
new filmmaker to take Akira in a
different direction so long as he gets
final approval he said I accepted the
offer for a live-action Akira to be made
so I am generally okay with whatever
they want to do with it however I did
give one major condition to do a
live-action version and that is that I
had to check and approve the scenario as
always the fundamental question on
adapting anything is whether you follow
the hosts work strictly or do something
new with it check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one